I don't see this here now with this one
I have to be fair and say you know what
maybe they told them no behave like this
or do this maybe possibility no problem
okay cuz they are them as a t
organization across the world yes not
across the world but a love of country
not all now here is something this video
really to by surprised I was like w whoa
who hold on a second but we know some
body language we know psychology a bit
we can understand you know facial uh
features this video was sponsored by
Master inah to be with confidence in
speak brother sister confidence is very
important confidence was one of the
things that led me to Islam not my own
confidence but the confidence of Zak the
confidence that he had in his religion
made me realize why is he so sure about
what he speaking and he made me listen
to him attentively so guys when it comes
to confidence and how to speak you need
this in marriage work colleagues friends
giving da so brother sisters many di
have also taken this course in please
check in the link below let's get
straight to the
video brothers and sisters and dear
friends I'm here with howd
we are in Italy why are we in Italy
brother and sisters we have brought the
Salah plus project alhamdulillah to
Italy and across Europe the side the
guided prats and open inubs we're here
for that we're here for that project
however ciao
Chia so guys but as you will see I was
get some updates of what's going on
across the world and we came across some
videos and we was like hold on a second
this is a little bit bizarre because
there was a lot of accusation
that was being made from all sides yes
no I think you're brushing over that
they were saying that any of these women
that have been taken you're going to see
them come they're going to be skinny
they're going to be pregnant their
babies are going to be killed they're
going to be put in microwave ovens you
see that all of these guy both these
women they're going to be graped all day
all night long watch when they come out
watch when they're out you're going to
see they they're not going to be
released they're going to I even saw one
of them saying a one of them are
probably 23 weeks pregnant right now as
we speak so let me just get this right I
think look you know what what we see
speaks louder so I think we flop that
saying still see seeing his Believers
seeing his believer I was looking yes
okay so we're going to watch some videos
uh we just find interesting because at
the end day one thing we need to bear in
mind when we looking at this hostage
situation is this here you see one
sister Palestinian hostage who was
released she's crying and saying mother
they were they were nearly killing me
they were nearly K they just literally
in tears but for some OD reason the most
Mor Army in the vote the only democracy
in the Middle East the most Humane I
would expect like what I'm seeing with
the other side with them it's just weird
so here is the video guys let's watch
for ourself and see what we can
take what is
this they look very
happy thumbs
up they look very healthy and well you
know you can know when someone's faking
it yeah you can know when someone is
being fake or being coerced yeah to a
certain degree you can say hold on a
second I don't see this here now with
this one I have to be fair and say you
know what maybe they told them no behave
like this or do this maybe possibility
no problem okay cuz they are them as a t
organization across the world yes not
across the world but a lot of country
not all now here is something this video
really told me by surprised I was like w
whoa who hold on a second but we know
some body language we know psychology a
bit we can understand you know facial uh
features
this is a fat girl that was dancing she
looks healthier than before bro she more
weight than
before you know how expensive it would
be for deep nice and healthy
yeah I think this only be bankrupting
them
I don't know if you know in video I've
done you done a video last as well there
was certain things I pick up some some
people don't not that special B the fact
that why was khabib on the plane now
with this one I don't know if you've
noticed yeah towards the end well I just
want to show you something here one
second I want to go here you're going to
mention the fact that the eyebrows are
done it looks they look exfoliate that's
actually I'm that's actually true cuz
Ira could go out there must be
Palestinian woman there helping them out
or whatever it is yeah bro there is a
nation that has been massacring your
people why would anyone cheer for them
bro they are treated like celebrities
have you noticed that the Palestinian
people are cheering their release would
you ever see from the other side when
the hostages H has been released and the
Israel are saying yes well we're so
happy bro they're on stage like a
celebrity they're smiling they know the
Arabic language they FL so much and the
Palestinians are cheering them they're
like we're celebrities bro what kind of
of a heart do you have to have what kind
of a kind soul you have to be that the
opposite side that's been massing you
and these are by the way they are
soldiers you know these girls were
soldiers they were not your oh no no no
these com IDF
combatants yes and we are being
objective here we're not I'm not
defending any side I'm just trying
objective here how is it that they are
being released and the people instead of
seeing you killed our children you
killed our babies you've done this
throwing rocks at them they are walking
with not SEC like secur just there just
you know some kind of order they're
being shared on well not not not only
that the fact that they exfoliated
glowing
skin be CER like a SP honestly like the
the big one she there was a clip of her
dancing before she looks masallah very
healthy
y I mean she looks very plump yeah she
looks um very
jolly this she
looks you know woman know this stuff
like oh my gosh the Skin's glowing they
like I nobody brings up a a a a cream
you know oh they use this it's it's to
me but then you know what's interesting
is then you then compare that with the
most moral Army most moral military in
the world bones and they they're not
only coming out in Bones the eyes sunken
into their socket to such a degree
you've got bet salm who's the human
rights organization of and from Israel
releasing a report titled welcome to
hell that talks about 10,000 prisoners
being tortured and abused without trial
yeah abused in these camps ranging from
the likes of getting rods stucking stuck
up your backside and rupturing your
internal organs to such a degree that it
goes to the doctor and even the doctor
like what the hell have you been doing
to these guys yeah and rather than them
being condemned and Outcast they're
paraded they're paraded just the way the
soldiers paraded pished that they mess
with them they have been interesting
contrast theyve been parading them bro
yeah they're parading them and saying
you know what you a rabbi saying you've
yeah you've you done this to an enemy
and no problem and this and that no
small army in the world in the world
don't here and they are being accused
we're just covering objective news here
we're looking at this matter objectively
I'll be honest with you if I was not a
Muslim or Pro Palestinian I will look at
this and be like yo hold on a second bro
bro do you know how many comments I've
seen on FL Muslim blond your Laura and
Sara and Michelle in the UK and they're
like you look at them and be like hold
on a second this is a te
organization but they are looking after
their hostages better and guess what one
of the girls we even saying if I'm not
mistaken that the people who were
protecting us against the shelling
meaning though this could go as far as
them saying they were protecting them
like when the shelling was happening he
were putting their life in the line of
these IDE of soldiers these are the idef
soldiers and to me let me tell you
something it just shows you guys that
the media is lying yes okay because at
the end of whatever you want to call
them you can call them the te whatever
that's up flat whatever the west of mode
however one thing that the Israeli the
most Moran in the world can learn is
from them they can literally learn how
to treat hostages because that is somewh
they like and everyone has noticed this
Muslim and un Muslim and the hostages
were being bought to the surface and
Tents getting that whole vitamin D and
all that they weren't just locked in a d
in a basement like they are in the
S camps so very good point I mean even
in terms of treating them as human
beings understanding that there is a
bigger cause and a bigger thing that is
that that is happening over here and
that is mostly to do with land and these
people and that's the problem like if
you're talking about freeing
hostages a counterargument to Israel's
notion of freeing hostages is why the
hell are you torturing 10,000 people
innocent people in a camp like how does
that make any sense whatsoever and it's
very interesting what he saying about
the news because the news naturally we
know in terms of funding in terms of
their Direction I mean the senior in the
BBC allegedly he there are people that
are whistle blown and said that he is
completely whitewashing the crimes of
Israel in fact he is pro Israel so
you've got these and BBC is supposed to
be the British Broadcasting whatever it
is um Corporation or whatever it is but
it's clearly a mouse piece for the
government is clearly a mouse piece for
foreign governments so this is something
like he mentioned we need to be very
careful that we do get balanced news
coverage from the left from the right
from the middle you know Al jazer who
are who obviously have more access over
there and just understanding that you
question everything that you see on the
news
exactly from Italy to the US and and UK
and everywhere ciao bye-bye